hello and welcome to another special usa
edition of
spectator tv we're delighted so many of
you over 200
000 of the last [ __ ] tuned into our
previous two episodes
and a special thanks to those of you who
gave us feedback and comments
some were even helpful please continue
to do so
and email at spectator tv at spectator
dot co dot
uk tv viewers can also get 10 percent
off
a subscription to our us publication if
they go to spectator
dot u s forward slash subscribe and
enter the promo code
tv we'll also throw in a free whiskey
tumbler
but sadly not the whiskey you know what
american liquor does are like
last night's first presidential square
off wasn't so much a debate as a
squabble
and an unseemly one at that it's not
entirely clear who won
perhaps joe biden because he didn't fall
in his face or disappear into a word
salad
yes the bar wasn't high for mr biden but
there is no doubt who lost
america and his reputation for robust
and intelligent
democratic debate the language of the
playground predominated so let me resort
to it by saying
donald j trump started it he heckled and
hectored his opponent from the start
and moderator chris wallace struggled to
control it
it was the worst presidential debate
i've ever seen
and i've seen them all way back to nixon
kennedy
though not lincoln douglas then they won
presidential debates you knew that
didn't you
anyway here are the low lights will you
listen who is on your list joe this is
who's on your right
gentlemen i think this is unbelievable
did you use the word smart so you said
you went to delaware state but you
forgot the name of your college
you didn't go to delaware state you
graduated
either the lowest or almost the lowest
in your class don't ever use the word
smart with me
he was a patriot and the people left
behind
there were heroes and i resent you
talking about
hunter are you talking about i'm talking
about my son beau biden you're talking i
don't know
i don't know beau i know hunter hunter
got thrown hunter got thrown out of the
military
but if i see tens of thousands of
ballots being manipulated
i can't go along with that and i'll tell
you what is that from a common sense
does that mean you're telling
other people it means you have a
fraudulent election
wait a minute you get the final word
well it's hard to get any word in with
this clown excuse me this
hey let me just tell you the first
presidential debate now to discuss
all of that i'm delighted to be joined
by the political strategist luke
thompson
poster marcus roberts head of
international projects at yougov
as well as the spectator's very own
amarathi and
freddie gray look first of all you're
the american here
how bad was it
it wasn't an edifying spectacle um
i i don't know that any televised debate
in the recent in recent ages has been
all that particularly useful for the
voters trying to make up their minds
most of these things are sort of
uh boring reality shows but last night
while not
boring definitely had all of the sort of
substance of your
your run-of-the-mill reality show
politically speaking
the person who needed to change the
dynamics of the race was president
i don't think that the president
succeeded in doing that
in many ways i think his team got what
they wanted
they got a flustered joe biden who five
days of full-time debate prep
had not made ready to answer anything
beyond the easiest questions
biden was easily rattled at times he
seemed lost and yet
his best friend on the stage last night
was not the moderator and it wasn't his
own team's preparation but the president
who kept bailing him out when he would
get stuck
trying to dance away from a question
like court packing that he didn't want
to answer so
insofar as as uh trump came in with a
strategy of throwing biden off of his uh
out of his comfort zone
and making him look silly that worked
and then they failed to close the deal
because they went too far
with the filibustering the thing is
amber the
the trump campaign mr trump himself
they've made much of mr biden's
cognitive decline
and we've seen some evidence of that on
the campaign trail some
quite embarrassing moments he had a few
dodgy moments last night but there was
no disaster for him was it
no it wasn't and the campaign should
have known better than to really hit
that
line of attack really hard because as we
saw in the
democratic primary debates joe biden
performed particularly well he didn't
really have
these types of gaffes that we would seek
when he's out on the campaign trail or
if he's talking to voters
and the campaign realized that far too
late and it was in fact
last week when they had their surrogates
going out on television and talking
about how much of a seasoned
and experienced and talented debater joe
biden is pointing to the fact
that of course he won the 2008 and 2012
vice presidential debates
but if you've spent an entire year
telling people
that this candidate has dementia
and is in cognitive decline and then
turn around a week before the debate and
talk about how they expect him to win
against their own candidate
it just comes across as really um too
little too late
freddie trump has a real gender problem
he's ahead with male voters
he's way behind with almost every
category of female voters
and i just wonder if that kind of
bluster the heckling the hectoring
the homes are sort of trying to bully
joe biden
i mean if you want female votes i would
suggest that may not be the best way to
go
about it well i agree and i mean i think
we hear a lot
about suburban mums suburban women being
the key demographic
in this race and if you look at a moment
like the
hunter bow moment in the debate last
night where
biden was talking about his dead son and
trump simply said
i don't know beau i want to talk about
hunter who is the
son with lots of allegations of
corruption surrounding him
i mean that seems to me i'm not a very
sensitive person
uh extremely callous uh i would have
thought a lot of women a lot of mothers
would have found that shocking
look mr biden was was interesting in
in the way several times he distanced
himself from
the left of the democrats he said i'm
the democratic party for now
he called his own plan a green new deal
but he said no it's not the aoc
bernie sanders green new deal which is
much more
extreme is that a sign of confidence
that he feels he
can distance himself from that part of
the democratic party that was calling
the shots during the primaries
well i think that the biden team would
push back on the notion that that
that part of the party was calling the
shots during the primaries
whether they were they would be right to
do that or not is a separate question
um the most telling moment in the debate
was
and where i think you saw biden get the
most uncomfortable
was when trump began to push him on what
would happen to public health insurance
a more able and detail-oriented debater
could have pinned biden on the fact that
his running mate kamala harris has said
eight different things about health care
but including getting rid of private
health insurance
that made biden very very uncomfortable
and that's when he sort of had his
uh let's moment where he said i'm the
democratic party
joe biden is not the democratic party
joe biden was not the first preference
of most democratic primary voters
uh he won because of a combination of
some fairly arcane primary rules some
good luck
and having deep reservoirs of support
with older black voters in the south
uh i don't think that he comes to this
from a position of confidence
uh i also don't think his his campaign
is thinking
one day past election day right now uh
if you can say anything for them
they're not measuring the drapes in the
oval office they are focused on on
keeping him in a position where he can
win given the lead that he has
right now um in terms of joe's
joe biden's relationship with the left
uh he tried to have it both ways last
night
um and trump helped him again trump's
insistence on bluster
bailed him out of a number of different
uh different situations that i think
another
more able more focused candidate could
have exploited biden referred to his
plan as the green new deal then said he
wasn't in favor of the green new deal
biden said he won the democratic primary
by opposing getting rid of uh
private health insurance but then turned
around and endorsed a public option
then he said the public option would
only apply to people already on medicaid
he was a mess last night and trump was
just so much messier that none of that
managed to be
uh you know highlighted or um or
amplified
uh i want to bring marcus in just a
minute to monster issues but amber let
me ask you this
will there be any stage in this campaign
where mr biden uh will sit down
with a well-informed interviewer and
raise these very points that luke has
been talking about
and pin him down on these points
know it's very unlikely and it's quite
funny to watch uh how chris wallace
moderated the debate last night and
actually
um assisted him in several key points
but when you look back at just a few
weeks earlier chris wallace was
constantly talking about how he was
inviting biden to sit down
for an interview with him like he did
with the president and how biden
continuously refused as we go through
the next two debates the moderators are
going to be even more left-leaning than
chris wallace supposedly is and so biden
has essentially gotten through the
toughest
type of questioning that he will ever
get from a reporter
and yet still he wasn't pinned down on
court packing he wasn't pinned down on
health care as luke said
and it would be silly for him to go out
of his way to sit down with a tough
reporter because he has nothing to gain
really by doing so
he he can only get through it if trump
keeps bailing him out which
which of trump is there uh will happen i
think
well it seems that a lot of lessons from
boris johnson have been learned uh
during the election campaigns about
getting interviews
marcus you gov did a snap pull after the
debate last night what were the findings
uh clear biden win 48 points to
joe biden 41 points to the president
um and within that everything you would
expect about how voters felt
uh the tone and temperament of the
debate was
83 percent of voters feeling that the
tone was negative
69 percent of voters saying that they
left the debate feeling annoyed
so what we saw and what we felt was very
much what the american people were
seeing and feeling
um abiding win thanks to the president's
poor and unpresidential behavior
and that i think is is really important
to bear in mind in terms of how it plays
out
with those crucial suburban uh female
voters
nicole wallace the republican strategist
said on msnbc last night
that in three presidential campaigns of
advising
republicans on how to win over larger
numbers of suburban women who are so
critical
to any republican or democratic
presidential campaign success
the one thing you don't want to do is
turn up and be unpresidential
be rude be arrogant be bullying and
those were all of the things that the
president
demonstrated last night and that's going
to be a problem for him
picking up those vital voters let me
look at the issues that came up in the
debate there was some discussion of the
issues in between the shouting and the
heckling
culvert mr trump's handling of it the
economy
uh healthcare law and order covert and
healthcare i would suggest playing to mr
biden's
physicians the economy and law and order
perhaps the minister
trumps was there any cut through on
policy though luke or
was it just repeating what we already
know
well i think in the in the case of of
trump prosecuting a
case against biden both for indecision
and for
um taking positions well out of the
mainstream of american politics there
were lots of opportunities
uh that you know um biden led with his
jaw on a number of fronts everywhere
from environmental regulation even in
areas where he's strong like health care
but
trump failed to deliver the blow the
first five to ten minutes of the debate
um it if you told me pick which
candidate spent five days doing
full-time debate prep i would have said
trump trump came out of the gate
he was aggressive and he was he was a
bit rude but
not outside of the mainstream of of
donald trump but he focused on
substantive issues and for the first
five to ten minutes of the debate it
looked like he was going to mop the
floor with joe biden
i think at that point we exhausted both
the restraint
that trump has um and also perhaps his
uh his preparation uh for details i
think the biggest areas where people
were looking for
a policy breakthrough are not around
covert of the economy
actually the polling there's been pretty
stable they've been split
vice president biden gets better ratings
on how he would have handled covet
trump gets better ratings on the economy
generally but i do think on health care
and environmental regulation
even more than law and order those were
big areas where there were there were
meaningful
distinctions between the two campaigns
that are going to have ramifications for
voters
and in both cases i felt like biden was
incoherent and trump was too
self-involved in his response to exploit
that incoherence and point to voters and
point out to voters both that biden
doesn't know where he stands and when he
does know it's probably well outside
what they want
but we'll hear more about the polls from
marcus in a minute but
mr biden is ahead in the national poll
for what that's worth
he's still ahead in the battleground
average
uh polls as well mr trump had to do
better than he did last night did he not
the trump
campaign must be disappointed he did
he did trump is is leading from behind
right now
and for him to really move the polls
last night had to be a stellar debate
and it really wasn't and i think
even people who are die-hard supporters
of the president you know i watched the
debate last night with about 40 other
conservatives
felt disappointed walking away from that
they felt like the president could have
and should have done much better
now the one good thing in the
president's favor is that he tends to
improve as these debates go on we saw
that in 2016 each debate with hillary
he was more measured better prepared and
able to land those blows rather than
just
pick away and be petty so if he's able
to keep up that trend as these debates
go on provided they don't get
cancelled because of how horrific the
first one is
then i do think trump has a chance to
make up some ground
of course the problem here is that so
many people are
early voting because of the coronavirus
and so the question is how many people's
minds are really
willing and able to be changed before
election day at this point and that the
polls
uh suggest very few i was struck for any
but i mean we know that sometimes
politicians honestly are two things that
pass in the night
but i was struck by both candidates
particularly mr trump that mr biden did
it as well
but they're just the massive quarters
they tell
you know mr trump saying this is until
kovalev was that greatest economy ever
with the greatest
job creation and all the rest of it and
mr biden saying that we gave you a
really fast growing economy
and you trashed it into recession and
all the rest of it
i mean do they know that they're just
talking nonsense when they say these
things
well i think i mean i i don't think it
really occurs to either of them
i think i think what you're dealing with
is
is um two different realities in america
and so in a way it's not really the
candidate's fault although
i think they did very badly last night i
think they're both speaking
to what they think are their bases and
that both their bases
as i say watch entirely different media
and exist in two different
realities and sort of the truth and sort
of anything reasonable
uh falls somewhere in between the two
marcus what do you think the takeaways
will be we we've got
the vice presidential debate next week
that will be interesting but it really
moves the dial on on anything
and then we've got two more presidential
debates one on october the 15th
and the final one on october the 22nd i
assume they're still
going to take place so i see some biden
people saying you shouldn't bother
turning up it was all the disgrace
but assuming they do take a place
would i not be right in thinking that i
mean if i was joe biden i would have
been very nervous last night in the
run-up to it
i'd approached the 15th of october now
with a bit more confidence would i not
i think that's very fair not least of
all because as amber was saying earlier
every day that passes in which the
president doesn't make up ground
is a day to the increasing advantage of
joe biden and the biden campaign
that's because of the sheer number of
votes that are being cast right now
in terms of early voting that will only
pick up and escalate exponentially
as we head towards mid-october and that
means that by the time
october 15th runs around if we uh
say that there's about this many
undecided voters left
right now there'll be about this many
left
by then what is happening uh in simple
terms
is that president trump needs to win
almost all of the undecided voters that
are left
and also reach into what is currently
biden's
electoral coalition which contains a
measure
of trump 2016 voters president trump
needs to win those people back
time is running out for winning them
back he didn't do it last night and now
he's going to wait
two weeks until he gets another shot at
trying to do so again
i'll come back to you for more details
in the post a minute just let me
uh go down first of all here to uh to
look
mr trump did not get the breakthrough he
needed last night or certainly wanted
what should he do come the second debate
to do better
in your view and can you
well you know
what's what's the first thing they say
you know you have to want to change
um and and i think that there there's a
question about
whether or not trump will want to
uh pivot into what his advisors stay is
a better
posture for winning these things um
here's here's how i would
frame it to the president to sort of
drive this home
four years ago he won in large part
on a single line by pointing to hillary
clinton and saying she says i'm with her
i say i'm with you he made the debate
about not just the voters
but who actually cared about the voters
uh the biden
campaign is clearly sensitive to that
concern they're clearly sensitive to the
the charge which trump made last night
that he will have done more in 48 months
than biden has done in 48 years in
politics
those are genuine weaknesses and so
biden repeated frequently
it's not about my family it's it's not
about your family it's about the
american family
etc he kept trying to push it back on
the voters the worst moment for trump
was at the end
when wallace asked about election
integrity and election security
and trump more or less went on a
20-minute tirade about himself
about the system being rigged about the
fake news about voter fraud
instead of talking about what he would
deliver in four additional years for the
voters at the
end of the day american voters vote for
president
not just based on who they think they
want to get a beer with although that's
a factor
not based on people's experience
although that's a factor
not based just on partisanship although
that's probably the biggest factor or
how foreign policy and the economy are
performing
but whether or not they view you as a
credible messenger
or a credible vehicle for advancing
their best interests over the next four
years
trump has to talk about that he has to
talk about voters he has to make this
about
the voters their expectations and who
can deliver for them
if he goes down more rabbit holes about
fighting with the moderator
or arguing about voter fraud then he's
going to miss the forest for the trees
okay that's what we talked about even
though in 2016 we learned that they
how shall i put it i'm not always
accurate or exactly on the button
uh especially in the battleground states
marcus you've been going through
the latest numbers you've got some
slides for us talk us through what the
polling currently tells us
okay well let's start with um the yougov
mrp uh this is the multi-level
regression with post-stratification
model
it rolls off the tongue it's a
big pole encompassing lots of different
sources of data
in this case there's 69 000 respondents
that went into this model
it's showing a clear lead for vice
president biden projecting that if the
election were held
today he'd be winning 53 to 44.9 in the
popular vote
and look at that electoral college
landslide 350
to 188 and that's because of the way
that voters are breaking currently
simply put it is currently more likely
that vice president biden wins
extraordinarily republican states like
georgia and texas
than it is that president trump manages
to put together a coalition to get back
to 270
and that's why vice president biden is
in the driving seat in terms of the
electoral college and the popular vote
right now
and if we move on and we see what is
driving this
you'll see that the composition of that
electorate that is
allowing biden to secure that lead is
the recreation of the obama coalition
of 2008 and 2012 rather than the clinton
coalition that was
insufficient to the job in 2016.
um look at those very high numbers of
support obviously
uh amongst uh african-american voters
and 2016 hillary voters but what's
interesting is that sliver
that important sliver there's five
points of donald trump
2016 voters that tend to be more
white blue-collar voters in the critical
battleground states that vice president
biden has won
back to his courts um what like
president biden has to do beyond this is
ensure that that hispanic number which
is historically still a little
south of where the democrats need it to
be continues to go up
if that goes up towards 70 you'd expect
vice president biden to win florida
and for election night to be very short
if that number stays down at 63
there's a good chance that the
republicans will take florida and we
could be settling in for a few weeks
of discussion to put it politely and
mildly over who's going to be the next
president
if we move on and see what the
favorability comparisons are
this is important because freddie and i
over a number of podcasts
for several months have been discussing
how important it is not just to look at
president trump's voting intention
number but also his favorability rating
and basically our rule of thumb has been
whatever number is
higher whether it's the favorability
number or the voting intention number
presume that's the number of people who
are going to vote
for the president and right now both of
those numbers
are in the low 40s for donald trump and
that's not where they need to be for him
to win the election
in comparison if we look at the next
slide we see joe biden's favorability
number is also
pretty close to what his voting
intention number is slightly south of
that
in comparison with the mrp i showed
earlier but that still shows the
difference
voters preferring favorability terms the
vice president of the president
now let's look at the next slide in
terms of the one great area of strength
for president trump which is on the
economy
and that is that uh despite everything
with regard to unemployment despite
everything with regard to growth despite
everything with regard to the
economic catastrophe of the coronavirus
pandemic
the president still has an advantage as
most trusted leader on the economy
and democrats will be seeking to chip
away at that advantage
probably by making more of the attack on
taxes
and finally let's turn to where uh
the debate ended up which is this
discussion of whether or not the
election itself will be fair
and whether or not the election um uh
will be resolved peacefully
and this is really concerning because
out of likely voters
27 percent of likely voters are saying
that they expect they only have a little
bit of confidence or none at all
that the election outcome will be fair
and that is a recipe for
serious concern about the democratic
process and let's conclude therefore
by looking at this question of
transition about
half of americans do not think there
will be a peaceful transition of power
if the outcome of the election is
contested and that takes me back to my
previous point
about florida which is the importance of
florida being called
on the night one way or another in order
to ensure
a short process rather than a long one
now there's one reason to hope that
actually the florida
process may be shorter than expected
which is florida
does allow for the counting of early
votes in advance of
the close of polls which means it won't
be the case that we're
uh having to wait on hundreds of
thousands or even millions of ballots
uh to be counted after polls closed in
florida
uh but if we end up with a close race
and a tight race in florida
and god forbid a 2000 style recount then
i think we'll be settling in
for quite a long contested contest
marcus i understand the thank you for
that in explaining that
the posters have made some uh
mythological changes
compared to 2016. i understand one of
the changes is they're allowing in their
samples they're allowing
much more for education that because
education had not been a
huge determinant historically of how
people voted
it wasn't taken much into account in
2016 but in
2016 it was a huge determinant
the less college degree you had the less
education
much more likely you were to vote for mr
trump has that has has the polling
now been adapted to take that into
account that is probably the biggest
single change in pollster methodology
over the last four years um and that's
the change that allowed pollsters
to go from getting the 2016 election
uh wrong at the battleground state level
to getting the 2018
midterms right at the battleground state
level
what it means is looking at whether or
not
um uh voters have a college degree
or or or not um and by ensuring that
that's a filter
in with the way in which poles are
constructed you get a more accurate
sample
so that along with the single simple
advantage that this cycle enjoys over
four years ago
we just have more high quality pollsters
polling the battleground states
more often which means that we don't
have to wait for so long or our averages
are skewed by a smaller pool of of
often less high quality pollster results
means that we should look i think with
more confidence uh
to the accuracy of the polls in this
cycle than that of four years ago
i was looking at the recent poll in
pennsylvania
to state mr trump probably has to win if
he used to stay
in the white house he won it last time
uh
and of course he wins it from the
western counties which are more rural
more blue-collar
and so the democrats rack up huge votes
in philadelphia
almost thought it was rather funny that
hillary clinton should choose to have a
final
rally in philadelphia city she was
already gonna win
because the other parts of pennsylvania
she was going to lose which she did
but the pulling this time showed mr
biden
naturally doing very well in
philadelphia i've been doing very well
in the suburbs among women too
doing twice as well as hillary clinton
did with women
and i i couldn't know how this but
holding his own in the western counties
and that combination gives on that
polling
gives mr biden pennsylvania is that a
broadly correct interpretation
that's very much the case because i
think if if you were to think of the
difference between the biden campaign
and the hillary campaign
as this the biden campaign believes that
politics is about
addition rather than subtraction the
hillary campaign
practiced a politics that said only the
purest of the pure
are going to be part of our electoral
coalition
and almost went out of its way at times
it seemed
to insult any number of the voters that
it actually needed to win
the biden campaign in contrast and you
saw this very much through vice
president
biden's uh addresses direct to voters
through the camera last night
is determined to win back the trust and
demonstrate respect
towards those voters that it doesn't
have and that it needs
and that political tonal difference
helps explain enormously
what's happening in western pennsylvania
okay look you're shaking your head there
what's your take
yeah i don't i don't i don't know that i
buy that at all um
i i don't see much of a tonal difference
between the vitamin campaign and the
clinton campaign what i
see is that clinton made certain gaffes
like saying we're going to put a bunch
of coal miners out of work in ohio
uh or just referring to to primarily
white working-class voters as
deplorables
and joe biden has been on both sides of
major issues i mean this is a matter of
obvious public record he said he's going
to ban
fracking now he says he's not going to
ban fracking that's an issue that is
very big in pennsylvania where the
energy economy depends on hydraulic
fracturing
but joe biden has not been forced to
account for these sorts of things
ultimately focusing on pennsylvania you
will have the same strategy that clinton
pursued
pursued by biden mobilized voters in
pittsburgh in the west
and philadelphia in the east persuade
suburban women in bucks county and the
other
philadelphia collar counties uh who are
primarily
middle and upper middle class uh white
suburban dwellers
and then try to minimize the amount of
damage that takes place
in the rural and ex-urban counties over
the rest of the state
um joe biden is doing the exact same
thing the difference is simply going to
be
whether or not biden can in fact turn
out sever
tens of thousands more black voters who
stayed home in 2016 i think there's a
decent argument that
he will be able to and whether or not he
will be able to persuade
uh suburban voters in the color counties
i think there's a reasonable argument
that he will be able to do that as well
so the strategies don't differ at all
the messages actually don't reasonably
differ in part because
both candidates clinton and biden have
taken both sides of multiple issues
but the treatment by the press that
biden has enjoyed is far better than the
treatment by the press the clinton
enjoyed
and frankly he's running against an
incumbent president with a terrible
economy whereas clinton
and trump were both running for an open
seat and those are fundamentally
different political dynamics but no
i think that the biden campaign will
tell you that they're trying to practice
politics of inclusion
versus clinton practicing a politics of
exclusion but i don't think that's
either a fair characterization or
of the clinton effort nor does it um nor
does it accurately reflect
the overall continuity and democratic
strategy especially in pennsylvania
between the two campaigns
quick reply marcus um
listening to luke i have a lot of
sympathy because it reminds me of
listening to democratic party or labour
party in the uk
critiques of boris johnson or of donald
trump four years ago i think a lot of
the points are very right about saying
how can you say this when you used to
say that um
when we examine the policy differences
don't we understand that there's a
bigger cleavage
a bigger difference but actually what
mattered in those elections and what
matt was the
way in which voters viewed those figures
and but joe biden is a much more
sympathetic figure
to white working-class americans than
hillary clinton was
and that allows him to do a politics
that isn't just based on the different
policy positions he may have taken
a more powerful personal politics that
allows that appeal to hit home
okay i just i dispute the notion that
there's a powerful personal politics to
biden that isn't a negation of donald
trump
i don't think that the entire scranton
joe schtick works i don't think it works
at all because he's been running that
stick
when he's running for president of the
last 40 years and the only time it's
ever worked was when he was seen as the
safest
highest probability chance to beat a
thermonuclear unpopular republican
incumbent in a democratic primary
electorate
so i i don't think that there are any
intrinsic personal values
uh about biden or his personality that
are propelling his candidacy i think
it's all
a politics of you hate trump i am the
safest vehicle to counter trump
pick me and i think it's going to get
him into the white house
let me bring in fredina and amber and
put a proposition
to you i'm beginning to think that the
trump campaign isn't some trouble now
the polls are not really moving the way
he would want them
that's nice performance everybody seems
to agree was not right
but and he seems to be positioning
himself
to lose to lose big time in the popular
vote
but then make a big deal out of the
mailing votes the popular
the votes counted on the day may well
give him
a sense of victory the votes counties in
the days afterwards
will could well put mr bagan ahead
and he's preparing that ground because
he's going to say hey
i won on the day these votes that have
come in all over the place and we
counted here there and everywhere
they're fraudulent it's a fiddle
you can't count them it's the only ones
that voted
on the day of mata he's almost preparing
the ground for defeat i would suggest
freddie
and then to have a fight to still try
and win i think that's exactly what it's
what he's doing
um and he possibly did it a little bit
in 2016 and was perhaps
surprised when he won but i think
what what um luke and marcus were
talking about was
it they actually agree in a way in that
biden is
uh the weak point of biden's campaign is
that he's a he's a phony really and
the trouble for the trump campaign is
they found him slippery to deal with
because
they want to call him sort of senile uh
sleepy joe et cetera
but actually sort of phony joe or or
sort of accusing him of lying which is
obviously what they said about hillary
clinton all the time
is a much more effective way of pinning
him down on his
are hypocrisy not signs of the trump
campaign
really does think he's going to lose but
it has a plan a dangerous plan
a plan that could well cause a
constitutional crisis
to grasp victory from the jobs of defeat
well it certainly feels that way with
all the interviews he's given
in terms of people asking him if he will
accept the results of the election and
he keeps saying
we'll have to wait and see and that's
precisely because of what you mentioned
which is that he is going to set the
ground for the
the mail-in ballot fraud and he did that
again last night of course when asked
about election
integrity by chris wallace and you know
i do want to hit on freddie's point
about joe biden being a phony because i
wrote an article for the spectator us
just yesterday
giving the trump campaign advice for how
to
attack this cult of personality or lack
thereof surrounding joe biden
as this um blue-collar champion because
his career has really shown the opposite
he supported trade policies like nafta
and tdp
and normalizing relations in china that
sent manufacturing jobs abroad and hurt
the working class in places like
detroit and pittsburgh and he also
um has lied repeatedly about his blue
collar roots
of course um his his presidential
campaign back in
88 was derailed by the fact that he had
plagiarized a speech from a british
politician
where he claimed that he was the first
in his family to go to college
and that his grandparents and parents
were coal miners and neither of those
things
turned out to be accurate for joe biden
so he plagiarized and lied
um if the trump campaign is able to
point out that yeah
trump is a billionaire he's never grown
up in the suburbs his parents
didn't work on uh selling oil heaters
but he maybe understands the policies
that affect the working class far better
than biden despite the fact that biden
has spent
his entire career in politics talking
about that
that's a much better message than
whatever happened on stage last night
marcus i finish up this segment with you
i don't know whether you've detected but
for those of us who like america want
america to do well
there's a growing concern that it could
be heading for a major constitutional
crisis
the the result will not be clear on the
night though mr trump may well
claim victory results are going to come
dribbling in for days afterwards which
could
change the overall balance of the vote
we move into an
interregnum of 11 weeks between voting
and the date of the inauguration 20th of
january
that bid is in the constitution and
america could be going through a huge
battle
over who has actually won the election
uh
and there'll be arguments about in some
states could even send two sets of
delegates to the electoral college
that's
happened before happened in 1876
who knows what happens when our biggest
ally the united kingdom's biggest ally
is is consumed with a constitutional
crisis
there was one that came close in 1932
the handover between hoover and fdr was
very messy
hoover was not at all helpful he tried
to stop things it was an
unpleasant handover during that time
when america seemed to be frozen
it came very close to social disruption
and uh hitler came to power in germany
and the
japanese uh invaded china what will
president xi
or president putin do in this 11-week
interregnum i think
the more i speak to people the more
concerned that regardless of whether
they're trump or
biden they are seriously concerned
about the chaos that could follow on
november the third what do you think
marcus
i'm someone who grew up in america
i worked there for 15 years before going
back to the uk
um i find it very painful watching the
debate last night
and listening particularly at the end to
the possibility
of of a contested election um and the
comments
uh around um via the potential of
violence
and i think you're right andrew that
there's a very real foreign policy risk
in all of this as well
um because when the world lacks strong
and stable american leadership
um the bad guys can get out of line um
and that's why the election needs to
have a clear and quick result
that's why there needs to be a strong um
and determined transition
um one can only hope that in the the if
if
there is a change of administration that
the trump administration will take a
lesson
out of the very successful bush to obama
transition model
um and what chief staff josh bolton did
there at the end of that administration
in order to ensure that america's role
on the world stage can
can uh uh continue in a strong and
positive way
but for those of us um who have a deep
and abiding love for america
uh it's very frightening to see these
democratic norms unraveling
and the prospect of of actual violence
in the wake of an
uh a a a an american presidential
election freddie
what do you make of it we all think in
the united kingdom we think we've got an
unwritten constitution
and so the passage of power the passing
of power from one to another
can be a bit messy but actually it's
really messy it usually
happens pretty seamlessly but we think
america with a written constitution well
the rules are laid down
it's got to happen this way and so on
but but when you look at the 12th
amendment
and the electoral counteract i mean
they're full of holes and ways of
interpreting and all
the rest of it and there's that
marvelous quote from the academic who
wrote the book on that
or or recent book on what might happen
after november the third
the the constitution does not guarantee
a peaceful
transfer of power it presupposes a
peaceful transfer of power
well i mean it depends on on a certain
amount of civility and goodwill on both
sides
oh well we'll be all right then because
that's obviously
that's what makes me even more worried
well what i what i worry about actually
is
i mean you know you hear a lot you talk
to people in britain about it they say
oh trump's a rogue you won't accept the
election result
i'm not sure a lot of people outside of
america realize just quite how
hypocritical the democrats are being
about this
i mean the sort of sanctimony which with
with which they talk about protecting
democracy and upholding it
all the while admitting that they're not
going to accept the result
i mean hillary clinton has told joe
biden to not accept the result
under any circumstances uh on election
night
um i think there's i think what a lot of
people outside america don't realize
is is the extent to which both sides are
cheating and i would say or
or planning not to accept the result and
i would say the democrats are being more
devious about it
than even trump but let me ask you uh
this because
how did america get itself into a
situation
where if it's going to have mail-in
votes as we would call them postal votes
that they're not counted on the day that
they have to be in by the day
as they do in britain and are then
counted
on the day together indeed in some cases
they're counted
in advance uh so they then add
the votes on the day on to the postal
votes and that night we get
the result has america got itself into a
position where
it could be days maybe even weeks and
you'll still
be using exclusive you simply count on
the bloody votes
i mean it's absurd right and i think the
one of the biggest contributors to this
is the fact that each state gets to set
its own rules
for how these mail-in ballots work so if
there were some type of
universal system i mean obviously the
argument can be made
that universal bureaucratic systems are
not very efficient either
but at the very least we'd all be
operating under the same set of rules
instead
every state has different ideas of when
they can start counting ballots
whether or not a ballot counts based on
how it's filled out
and and really we're setting ourselves
up for this really nasty fight between
all of these different localities
and it's really concerning you know i
actually am moving in a couple of weeks
and i've been dealing with the virginia
board of elections
and i've been less than pleased with how
they're handling that i mean
all i really had to do supposedly was
send in the change of address form
and yet when i checked the online
database just yesterday to see the
status of my
address change it turned out that i was
no longer in the system at all so now
i'm going to have to spend probably
several hours on the phone with the
board of elections
trying to make sure that i can vote come
november 4th um so i can only imagine
what's that what that is like when you
scale it up to all of these other people
who are
trying to be sure that their votes are
going to count on election day
and then look at all the different rules
from all the different states across the
country
it is going to be an absolute mess to be
sure
andrew can i jump in to give people some
peace of mind on this because i think
there's a lot of
anxiety that may not be that may not be
well anchored
um two two of the best states accounting
votes in america are ohio and florida
and we're going to probably get good
results from them early on
on election night if not you know
shortly after midnight the day after
election day
there are essentially three factors when
it comes to counting absentee ballots
one is opening the envelope the other
is doing a signature check to make sure
that the affidavit signature matches the
signature on record
for the person who who is casting the
ballot and then the third is tabulating
vote tabulating the votes is all done by
machines and that takes almost no time
at all
so ohio and florida do not tabulate the
votes until election day but that's just
a matter of running
running through machines either at
precincts or some of them do it at
centralized county level facilities uh
where you have observers from both
parties
um the challenge is taking the
vote out of the ballot out of the
envelope and doing the
affidavit signature check and that takes
a lot of time and in places where people
who are either
disproportionately elderly populations
or where they haven't voted by mail
before
you can get a lot of problems that jump
up here because they
don't sign the affidavit line or they
have a signature that's at variance with
the signature that's on record
they don't have a signature on record
etc and
as in say new york city during the
democratic primary this summer where 20
of ballots were thrown out i think in
queens or one of the one of the boroughs
um that was largely a byproduct of
signature failures
um and incomplete absentee ballot
filling out by voters who hadn't done it
before
so in critical swing states i don't
think we're going to see a whole lot of
problems i think we'll be fine in ohio
and i think we'll be fine in florida
um you will have large and protracted va
uh vote counting situations in
california
and in new york and elsewhere where the
rules are a kind of toxic combination of
allowing votes to come in late
and preventing the uh elections
officials from even beginning the
process of of
opening matching and tabulating until
after election day
but that's really not gonna be a
question on election day so i think a
lot of this is
is people working themselves into a
frenzy to my
mind the odds of a of a violent
transition of power
uh are extremely low and the one
instance that we didn't talk about yet
on this uh on this
discussion is 2000 where we went for
over a month without a settled winner
things had to go up to the supreme court
where al gore's argument that he should
only have to recount
heavily democratic counties in florida
was shot down by the supreme court
and george w bush was made the next
president we will be fine
we will be fine everybody just needs to
relax
everybody needs to vote and it will be
fine
all right look you've helped to reassure
me i'm not totally convinced because i
can
say that these signatures will become
the hanging chads of 2020
that's where all the legal challenges
will be a bit of because it won't matter
so much if it's california
or new york because nothing will change
the outcome of these
states uh and it is the battleground
states we should look at
so andrew biden has got 600 teams of
lawyers across the country all ready to
challenge
yes the signatures already 300 lawsons
that's normal
this this those guys this is normal like
it's litigating
lawyers yeah lawyers are unfortunately
part of the process now
alas indeed they are unfortunate
indeed but it is america uh we got to
know a bit about donald trump's income
tax returns this week thanks to the new
york times
and surprise surprise he pays highly any
income tax at all according to the new
york times
story i guess so many of his companies
make losses he's up to his neck in debt
as well
which of course you can write off before
you pay tax and that gave meant that i
think in one year he paid
750 uh dollars uh amber perhaps no
surprise in the end that he doesn't pay
much tax
it may not upset his base because
nothing
seems to upset them but it must cause
some people to ponder
i really don't think so you know trump
uh not releasing his tax returns was
supposed to be this huge issue in the
2016 election
people didn't really care about it and
now people
uh when they are seeing his tax returns
they're actually getting the sense that
he might be a better businessman than
they realize
sure he has all of these losses and and
debts but he's also managed to somehow
be a billionaire who only paid 750
in one year i think that's admirable to
a lot of normal americans who are always
trying to get over on their taxes
so it might be somewhat frustrating for
some people but i think they also
are are more envious than they are angry
at him
well he is he is a debt he's a
billionaire he's a debt billionaire
uh that's different from being a
billionaire like bill gates or mr bessos
but do americans really think i mean
doesn't easily american view is that
entrepreneurs business people
they invest they create lots of jobs
they create new businesses
often world beating and they pay taxes
to pay for
infrastructure and welfare and so on i
mean
mr trump hasn't done any of that sure
but this was an argument in 2016 as well
i think that this issue has just already
been litigated and already been decided
by the american people hillary clinton
made the point over and over again that
trump was not as wealthy as he claimed
to be
that he was a fraud that he wasn't
contributing to the system
and that ended up not really being a
deciding factor for voters on election
day so i
while this is relatively new information
in terms of the actual
seeing the actual tax returns the
attacks that come from it are not new
look that would make if amber's right it
would make america the only
democracy in the world that doesn't
uh care if a billionaire claimed bill
you know self-certified billionaire uh
pays less tax than a primary school
teacher
well without going into the arcane
details of where tax gets collected
um i think that the 750 number is a very
helpful talking point
for uh democrats but if his final line
on his tax return was 750
uh to the federal government um at the
end of the year
that doesn't take away from millions of
dollars paid to state
local and federal authorities either
through his companies or as an
individual
um over the course of a year and and i
also think
this is this you know hillary clinton
pointed out in a debate four years ago
that donald trump didn't pay income
taxes
we know this as amber says this is not
something that's new
um what donald trump will point at is
the skyline in manhattan
and say look i contributed massively to
developing this
you want to know what i've done to help
increase the economy i've built these
buildings that put people to work
what has joe biden ever done those
buildings are how i became a billion
a millionaire how did joe biden become a
millionaire and i don't think that's a
comfortable conversation for democrats
so
if i'm democrats looking at the new york
times story i say great 750 put it on
the battle
flag and let's move on because it's
stylized
there's no sense of equity in this at
all that if
if you're rich and you make lots of
money uh
you should pay your fair share of taxes
uh not penal taxes that would send you
abroad or
wherever but just pay your fair share
there's no
concern about that i think every i think
every american knows that our tax code
is is filled with carve-outs outs
especially carve outs around real estate
and construction and that
people expect it to be arcane and they
know that people pay taxes to lots of
different entities through lots of
different means
and so in my view it's highly unlikely
that this is going to become an equity
question but more reinforce the sense in
people's minds
uh that we have a byzantine tax code
that rewards some behaviors and punishes
others
if donald trump was a corporate
executive who had a w-9 and was a run a
rank-and-file employee even a senior
executive
and was only paying that much income tax
it would be a much different
issue but as someone who owns his own
businesses and especially businesses
heavy in real estate
it's much easier for him to make
explanations to people
look you write off your mortgage
interest deductions
i write off losses on my buildings i
take loans against
assets you people understand how this
works
if not in the detail than in the general
sense that's what he's doing because
it's the banks that are in this building
it's not him
marcus this is an example of american
exceptionalism
isn't it i mean i can't think of any
european democracy
ours included in which a self-styled
billionaire
it was then who had refused to release
his tax
returns there it was but was then
discovered
that he'd paid 750 dollars in tax
i mean in in any other in a european
democracy would that not be a huge issue
that would probably be a game changer in
any european uh tournament
for whoever was in that position the
campaign would be over oh oh oh
without question um now in the uh poll
that followed
um the tax revelation um hugo found that
58
of americans uh believe the story to be
completely or somewhat true
um that 52 of americans believed it was
inappropriate for the president to have
acted like this
but 35 percent of americans believed
that it was appropriate
what does that tell us it tells us that
partisanship is one hell of a drug
it tells us that the supporters for
president trump
are prepared to find any way to justify
support
and the supporters of president biden
are prepared to always see
the problem with president trump the
question is whether or not this becomes
as luke was saying at the start
something of a sharp dagger attack
for the democrats on president trump on
the wider issue of the economy
because as we noted earlier up until now
president trump has enjoyed a small but
but solid lead in terms of uh being the
preferred choice for
economy handling over vice president
biden and if this becomes a kind of 750
sound bite that actually has resonance
um
at an emotional level then perhaps you
see that number shift a little bit
there's no sign of that uh yet but we're
in early days and we'll keep an eye on
that in the polls
freddie give you the final word on this
well i just i always think about a
conversation i had in 2016 with a voter
i think it was in cleveland
a guy who's going to vote for trump and
um
i said in a sort of pompous british way
i said to you don't you think donald
trump's a bit of a crook
and he said oh sure but but all the guys
in washington are 25 cent crooks
and trump is the whole dollar crook uh
and he meant that enthusiastically
uh and and i think that is american
exceptionalism they take a very
different attitude to it and
the thing about biden is is you know the
hunter biden and where he got his money
from questions are real
and that's the sort of corruption that i
think americans hate particularly
because it's about it's washington
corruption
whereas trump can say you know i i i got
away
i tried to reduce my tax burden uh in
the name of building
big buildings this is the corruption of
the property interests which both
democrats and republicans
have been guilty because they came up
with tax codes
which are hugely advantageous to
property developers
yes that was a very funny bit in the new
york times uh
massively long report on it where the
sort of reporters seem to discover that
um it's because of an obama change in
the law in 2004
that trump was able to offset so much
and and that's heartbreaking to them but
it's but it's true both sides have
connive to make no both parties have
responsibility for that and there's no
sign it's going to get any better
mind you the british tax code isn't that
much better either i think it's one of
the longest in the world
uh we've got five minutes i want to come
to amy connie barrett the
nominee for the supreme court devout
catholic mother of seven
uh the hearing start um chaired by
republican senator lindsey graham
who i see him maybe in a little bit of
trouble in his own state
there beginning on october the 12th what
i just want to find out from you all
is that as these hearings get underway
in the
three weeks in a bit right up to the
election
is this helpful to mr trump to have this
kind of battle
or is it unhelpful amber
i think it's incredibly helpful if we
use kavanaugh in 2018 as a guide because
what happened then
was the democrats went way over their
skis and
attacked him for these insane and
unproven
sexual assault allegations and
unfortunately for republicans that
happened
a bit too far ahead of the midterms to
have a real effect
but i talked to so many conservatives at
that time that described themselves as
being radicalized
by the what they saw as as an
evil that the democrats were doing if
they go into the amy coney barrett
hearings with the same fervor
and the same willingness to destroy her
and her family at all costs
then that's going to have a huge
blowback on the democratic party in
general so
it's helpful to trump insofar as it
makes his party
look better rather than him personally
look is this why we get we hear that
some democrats
don't want to do a kavanaugh this time
that although they don't want her to be
the nominee
they may not push the boats out to try
and stop it
look well i there are conflicting
interests
among democrats in the senate so as
individuals every democratic senator on
the judiciary committee wants to have a
moment where they're asking hard
questions and really
you know taking a brick back to amy
coney barrett because they can raise a
ton of money that way
on the flip side amy coney barrett is a
midwestern uh white ethnic catholic from
notre dame
uh you cannot get a more quintessential
figure uh she's a suburban mother
um relatively young if kamal harris or
maisie hirono or dianne feinstein are
perceived in the hearings to be
attacking coney barrett for her
life choices being a mother of seven uh
for her faith
being a devout catholic that will
resonate in swing states like michigan
like pennsylvania like ohio
like wisconsin where you have large
catholic populations
a lot of whom cheer for notre dame
marcus mr biden last night in the debate
he said some nice things about him
recording but barry it made me wonder if
you i mean he's very worried about roe
v wade as are many nearly all those
opposed to her
appointment but i did begin to wonder
if he really thought this was the fight
that should be grabbing the headlines
between the opening of the hearings of
november the third
i think what luke just said is very
important about
um the democratic party needing to be
very careful with its handling of this
with regard to the uh huge importance of
the catholic vote
um in those battleground states uh and i
think the bite i think that joe biden
demonstrated his awareness of that in
terms of his
uh as you put in andrews surprising uh
response um to the question
i don't think there's an appetite at all
on the part of the biden campaign
to make this um the major issue uh in
the home stretch of the election they
want to keep the focus on coronavirus
they want to keep the focus on the
president's handling of that
in as much as there's a discussion of
the supreme court
the biden campaign and the democrats
know that they're on a stronger ground
when it's
uh talking about defending the
affordable care act
and ensuring uh the protection of
pre-existing condition
medical provisions within that they
don't want to get into
a public fight over roe versus wage in a
public fight
over abortion not because the national
politics
on abortion after all um uh currently
support for overturning roe versus wade
only rested about 25 in terms of
of the national picture uh but rather
because as luke was saying before
about the preponderance of catholic
voters
in those crucial battleground states and
a desire to keep the focus on something
else
namely the coronavirus pandemic and the
president's handling of that
in the home stretch freddie final
question to you
when uh john f kennedy ran for president
in 1960 the fact he was a catholic was
quite a big issue
uh particularly in states like west
virginia and his father had to buy west
virginia
so that he could uh could win it uh
because i have a big
presbyterian uh state now we're in a
situation where there could soon be
i think you're a catholic fairy i knew
there could soon be six catholic supreme
court justices
if you can't go such who was raised as a
catholic you could say
seven should the rest of us start to get
worried are you
going to bring back the inquisition or
something like that as a sinister left
footer
i can tell you it's all part of the plan
uh it's going to plan isn't it and and
the call is the right place where we can
sit in judgement
on everyone else but i would say
actually i'll just rush in a
plug for the latest spectator
of the american edition uh which has a
fascination
about the role of religion in america
which of course ties into this and it's
interesting that
while religion seems to have disappeared
a little bit as a matter of public
debate in politics
it now seems to manifest itself on the
supreme court
and i think there's a lot of very
interesting questions to be asked about
that
okay and that's a great cover story uh
we've got to go now thanks to all the
guests today it's great to talk
to you thanks to you for tuning in to
another episode of spectator tv
usa election special if you want to hear
more from spectator journalists
of the kind that we've had on this
program subscribe to the spectators us
edition you'll get to read that great
cover story go to there he is
he's the salesman marketing director and
actually you see him standing on the
street corner
you'll go to heaven
[Laughter]
he's catching he believes in him
spectator.us
is the website forward slash subscribe
you get a discount
if you enter code tv do so you won't
regret it
it's really rather cheap as well or
should i say inexpensive
thank you see you next week bye bye
you